تحدث اطباء فرنسيون عائدون للتو من غزه
لصحيفه ليبراسيون الفرنسيه عن مشاهداتهم
في القطاع فوصفوا الوضع بانه ماساوي وفوق
التحمل تحدث الاطباء عن انتشار الموت
بالقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يمارس قتلا
غير قانوني وغير مبرر احد الاطباء تحدث عن
تجربته القصيره في القطاع وقال عملت في
مناطق سوريه محاصره وفي اوكرانيا بعد
الغزو الروسي لكن ما شاهدته في غزه غير
مسبوق يرى الكاتب ليف رينب في ارتس ان
الحاله الوحيده لانهاء الحرب على غزه يكمن
في الاحتجاجات الشعبيه من قبل
الاسرائيليين والضغط الدولي مشددا على عدم
وجود حل عسكري للقضيه الفلسطينيه ويشير
الى ان خروج اسرائيل من غزه واعاده الاسرى
والجنود الغارقين هناك في الوحل وفق
تعبيره ليس اولويه الان ما دامت القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه مستمره في التمسك
بالنصر ورفض الحلول
السياسيه في مجله فورين افيرز كتب الف بن
عما سماه التدمير الذاتي الذي تمارسه
اسرائيل بسياساتها العدوانيه تجاه
الفلسطينيين ويرى الكاتب انه لا مفر
لاسرائيل من التصالح مع الفلسطينيين اذا
ارادت العيش في سلام ولا يمكن
للاسرائيليين ان يتوقعوا الاستقرار اذا
استمروا في تجاهل حقوق الفلسطينيين ورفض
تطلعاتهم بل وحتى
وجودهم دعم م حمد بازي ف الجارديان الرئيس
بايدن الى اجبار اسرائيل على انهاء الحرب
والا فان صراع واشنطن مع الميليشيات
المدعومه من ايران سيتصاعد كما قال واضاف
الكاتب ان بايدن يمتلك القدره على كبح
جماح اسرائيل لكنه يرفض استخدامها موضحا
ان اداره بايدن بذلت قصار جهدها لاخفاء
حجم شحنات الاسلحه والمساعدات الامريكيه
لاسرائيل على عكس ما فعلت بشان الشحنات
الهائله من الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا الى موقع ميديا بارت الفرنسي
وتحليل ينتقد قرار الرئيس امانويل ماكرون
تكريم الفرنسيين الاسرائيليين ضحايا هجوم
حماس واعتبر ان ذلك يكرس المعايير الغربيه
المزدوجه ويعمق الانهيار الاخلاقي
والسياسي القاتل في فلسطين ودعى الموقع
فرنسا الى وضع حد لحاله الانكار التي
تعيشها بخصوص
غزه نقلت مجله نيوز ويك عن محللين قولهم
ان تصاعد التوتر في البحر الاحمر قد يتسبب
في موجه جديده من ارتفاع التضخم العالمي
وعرقله سلاسل داد وهو ما قد يؤدي بدوره
الى ارتفاع الاسعار ولفت المحللون الى ان
اكبر منطقه تاثرت بالتاخير هي اوروبا على
الرغم من ان الوصول المحدود عبر قناه
بانما قد يضع الولايات المتحده تحت الضغط
ايضا ختام لوموند الفرنسيه تطرقت الى موقف
الصين من التوتر في البحر الاحمر يرى
التحليل ان بجين فضلت النايه بنفسها بعيدا
وتجاهل طلب واشنطن منها التدخل لدى ايران
ويضيف ان الصين تجني فوائ من بقائها خارج
اللعبه اذ علاوه على ان اقتصادها لم يتضرر
من تعطل حركه الملاحه في البحر الاحمر
تدرك ان التدخل المباشر له
[موسيقى]
ثمن